*Sirène de voiture de police*
*Voix dans un talkie walkie*
Qu'est ce qu'on a?
Un homme, 40 ans.
Ça fait plus d'une heure qu'il est là,
il menace de sauter
et il veut pas qu'on l'approche.
Sale journée hein?
On est tous passé par là.
On va discuter d'accord?
Nan j'ai pas envie de discuter!
J'ai plus envie de rien.
Foutez moi la paix!
Ok, ok.
Ça t'ennuie si je m'allume une clope?
Bah, non.
Tu fumes?
J'ai arrêté.
Bravo.
Moi, je m'appelle John.
Curtis.
Enchanté Curtis.
Bon dis moi,
c'est quoi le problème?
Le problème,
c'est que la vie c'est de la merde.
Voilà, j'ai plus de boulot.
J'ai plus de fric, plus d'amis.
Je vais perdre ma baraque.
Je suis au fond du trou...
Il y a bien un truc
qui vaut le coup sur cette Terre?
T'es marié non?
Oui j'ai une femme et deux gosses.
Hé ben ça, ça vaut le coup
qu'on s'accroche non?
Oui ils m'ont toujours soutenu,
même dans les pires moments.
Les enfants ça change la vie.
Ouais c'est vrai.
Vous en avez?
Nan.
Vous êtes marié?
Ben vous avez une fiancée, une copine?
Non non.
Peut-être une coloc
avec qui c'est un peu ambigu?
Parce que parfois c'est-
Non, non, je vis seul.
Oooow...
Je l'aimes ma famille vous savez.
C'est pour ça, je peux pas
leur imposer un loser comme moi.
Je suis une merde.
Mais non !
Mais si!
Depuis toujours!
Vous savez j'ai sucé
mon pouce jusqu'à 8 ans!
Mais c'est rien ça, c'est du passé!
Moi j'ai pissé au lit jusqu'à 16 ans donc...
Quoi?
Non non rien.
Rien!
Il a dit qu'il pissait au lit jusqu'à-
Oui bah c'est bon!
C'est celui qui a le mégaphone
qui parle, d'accord?!
Jusqu'à 16 ans!
16 ans c'est super tard non?
C'est carrément bizarre ouais!
C'est pour ça que vous trouvez personne?
Non mais l'important
c'est d'avoir arrêté.
Exactement Curtis.
T'as arrêté de sucé ton pouce
et t'es devenu un homme,
un mari et un père de famille.
Et ça c'est pas rien.
Ah bah non ça c'est pas rien.
C'est même beaucoup !
On est rien sans
l'amour d'une famille.
Désolé!
Non non c'est rien...
Écoute-moi bien Curtis...
Encore une clope?
Pardon?
Non, rien.
Vous fumez beaucoup quoi.
Ouais je sais,
j'ai essayé d'arrêter mais-
Vous avez essayé de vapoter?
Parce que j'ai un pote qui a fait ça et-
J'ai tout essayé,
j'y arrive pas.
De tout façon j'arrive à rien.
Ah ben vous avez réussi
à être policier quand même.
C'est pas tout le monde qui peut y arriver.
Hmpf.
Quand même !
Vous protégez la société,
vous vous occupez des gens.
C'est super!
Ouais super ouais.
Je m'occupe des gens
et puis quand je rentre à la maison,
qui s'occupe de moi?
Personne.
Vous avez bien des amis non?
Bien sûr!
Quand faut faire sauter les PV,
j'en ai plein des amis!
Y a forcément
des gens qui tienne à vous?
Votre collègue là,
elle a l'air de bien vous aimer.
Jusqu'à 16 ans!
Si, je te jures.
Haha !
Non mais le point positif...
C'est que j'ai ça !
Comme ça si j'ai envie d'en finir,
je peux faire ça
tranquillement à la maison.
Non mais dites pas
des trucs pareil !
Tiens je vais peut-être
faire ça ce soir, pourquoi pas ?!
Quoi?
De toute façon je vais
manquer à qui ? Hein?!
Non non mais déconnez pas!
Restez là!
Monsieur ça va?
Oui oui ça va.
15 ans je crois.
Non 16 !
Jusqu'à 16 ans.
16 ans.
D'accord très bien.
Chéri!
Coucou!
Ça va mon amour?
Ça va, et toi?
T'as encore fait le coup du célibataire!
Et ouais.
Mon héros...
Par contre t'as encore pissé au lit.